[Music]
in dakar's chariot suburb a 13-year-old
boy is doing what senegal's government
is struggling to do keep the lights on
for his family and neighbors fed up with
the constant power cuts falucin uses
material found in trash to build solar
powered lamps
[Music]
i used batteries scrap metals electrical
wiring all solar panels and light bulbs
it doesn't take much we have all the
resources we need to power our homes i
don't understand why it's so hard to
bring electricity to our families
almost half of the country is not
connected to the power grid run by
cinelec the state-run electricity
company traditional land-based power
stations are costly and take time to
build
montana
we need two billion dollars to provide
electricity to all but our national
budget can't afford this but there are
private contracts as they can do the job
better that's what we're hoping for
centerlink is turning to these floating
power plants run by turkish owned car
powership to meet its immediate needs
dock into cars port it burns a thousand
tons of fossil fuel in just five days it
is also connected to a boat offshore
carrying liquid natural gas we can
progressively switch from heavy fuel oil
to natural gas and this will have to
impact first thing reduction in the
electricity price second thing more
friendly to the environment
at least eight african countries and 30
worldwide rely on these floating power
stations to meet their electricity needs
every 15 minutes an engineer from the
national power station
sends a text message to the crew on the
ship indicating the amount of
electricity senegal needs at its peak it
provides 25 percent of senegal's power
millions of people depend on it but few
can afford the price of power
senegal's electricity price is among the
highest in the world more expensive than
most european and north american
countries mother of nine isotope is
forced to choose between food or power
it's such a difficult choice to make one
that i'm forced to take
i have hope though that someone god
willing will find a solution
while the government promises to deliver
electricity for all by 2025 falucin sees
an opportunity to help take small steps
to bring power to the people nicholas
hawk al-jazeera charoi senegal